[ice clicking]
[quiet thudding]
Narrator: Look at these two paper bags.
They don't appear very different,
but they sound different.
One of these is a real,
everyday paper bag,
[bag rustling]
and the other one is a silent prop.
[bag quietly unfolding]
This fake paper bag was an innovation
thought up by prop maker Tim Schultz.
Props is always about solving a problem.
Narrator: And one of those problems
is everyday objects that
don't look distracting,
but sound distracting.
I often say that a sound guy can hear
grass growing when you're on location.
Narrator: Silencing
some props, like drums,
can be fairly simple,
like adding a drum mute.
[drum booms]
[muted drum thuds]
But others require getting
a bit more creative,
like with pool balls, which were too loud
for these two bar scenes in season one
of "Friday Night Lights."
Man: Nice shot!
Narrator: Property master Scott Reeder
needed to find a ball that would create
a softer sound on impact.
First, he experimented with
plastic balls from a ball pit.
They were much quieter,
but he couldn't get paint
to stick to the surface.
Then he remembered a trick he used
on 1991's "Necessary Roughness"
during a shot where a character is thrown
onto a pool table in a bar fight.
Reeder swapped real pool
balls with racquetballs,
so the actor would land
on something softer.
We didn't really clue in at the time
that, oh, you know, these
would be good for sound.
Narrator: Listen to how
real pool balls sound.
[balls clacking]
It's too noisy.
Narrator: Compared to the racquetballs.
[quiet thudding]
Much better.
Narrator: To get it to
look like the real thing,
Reeder added a layer of primer
to make sure the paint stuck,
followed with a glossy spray
to give off the signature
shine of a real pool ball.
Reeder: You gotta pick them up
to tell that they're not real.
Narrator: And Reeder also had to know
when to swap the props in.
Reeder: If actors are playing in a scene,
we'll typically do real
if the camera's going to
see them hit the ball.
And then when the camera goes
to where it's just on their face,
we'll throw the fake ones on the table
so they can actually play pool.
That way, the sound man
can catch the dialogue.
Narrator: Prop masters don't always need
to find a replacement.
Some silent props are made
by just modifying the real thing.
For example, in this scene in "Tammy,"
actress Melissa McCarthy needed to wear
a paper bag on her head
to hide her identity
and another one on her hand to hide a gun.
Schultz said it was important
for her to use the real thing,
but a real paper bag would
sound something like this.
[paper rustling]
Tammy: You want some pies?
Worker: I like pie.
[paper rustling]
Tammy: Well, get a pie,
you get a pie for --
Narrator: Quieting these real bags down
meant adding more weight to them.
So Schultz sprayed the bags
with a mix of water and glycerin,
which is typically used
to add the appearance
of sweat or water droplets
on anything from human
skin to beer bottles.
Schultz: Takes quite a bit of --
well, it takes time and finesse,
'cause you don't want to overdo it.
Narrator: He also taped the bags inside
to hold them together and
prevent them from crumbling.
But this fix was only temporary,
since the bags would
eventually lose their color
and fall apart over time.
And this wouldn't work for when actors
have to handle bags consistently.
So for other projects, Schultz developed
a quiet, durable, alternative
using fibrous nonwoven fabric.
This is actually the same
material as coffee filters.
To make it look like the real thing,
Schultz wraps the fabric around a mold,
then he glues and folds the sides by hand.
Schultz: We're trying to copy the bottom
of a standard bag that's
really made by a machine.
It's important to get the
corners so that they're square.
A lot of times we'll,
when we're using them,
we'll crinkle them and
make them look more used,
so they have a more realistic look.
Instead of cutting it smooth,
it's going to cut it with
a little jagged edge to it.
Narrator: This fabric can be used
on other paper products as well,
like when this butcher
in "The Kominsky Method"
talks to Alan Arkin while grabbing
a handful of cold cuts.
That butcher paper?
Fake.
[paper rustling]
It's these small handheld props
that give prop masters the most trouble,
especially in scenes with dialogue.
For example, an actor with a drink
will likely hold it near their midsection,
where microphones are often attached.
It's especially important to make sure
whatever is in that drink
doesn't produce any unwanted sounds.
So if you're watching
a show like "Entourage"
with lots of scenes at parties and bars,
it's safe to assume that
these ice cubes are all fake.
But not all fake ice is the same.
Plastic cubes don't melt,
which is great for continuity,
but they're still really loud.
[cubes clicking]
So when sound is crucial,
Schultz often opts for
another type of fake cubes.
These ones, made out of silicone.
These rubber cubes can
either be molded in trays
or ripped apart.
Since the final product floats in a glass,
they look more convincing.
[ice softly clunking]
And, best of all, they're
completely silent.
Schultz: Background actors
can move this stuff around
without having to worry about the sound.
Narrator: So when this waitress walks by
with a trayful of cups with ice,
you can hear ...
Turtle: What time's dinner?
We're starving.
Narrator: And not ...
[ice clinking]
Turtle: What time's dinner?
We're starving.
Narrator: While ice cubes only
pop up in certain moments,
other loud materials are everywhere.
Like plastic.
Everything from sandwich
bags to potato-chip bags
make loud crackles.
So Schultz will create
fake ones out of vinyl.
So, this material,
[dull crackling]
it's that dull sound.
Narrator: And it comes in handy
for other places you might not expect,
like flower bouquets that
are wrapped in cellophane.
Take this moment from
"The Kominsky Method"
where Michael Douglas' character
brings flowers to an ailing friend.
If Schultz had used real
cellophane for the bouquet,
all the sound team would hear is ...
[plastic crackling]
What kind of flowers
are those?
[plastic crackling]
I have no idea.
Narrator: So, he used a
transparent vinyl material
to replicate the look
without all the noise.
What kind of flowers are those?
I have no idea.
Uh-huh. So your daughter bought them?
Yeah.
Narrator: But no solution
is one-size-fits-all.
[tissue rustling]
Noisy tissue,
but a quiet bag.
[tissue rustling]
Still doesn't solve the problem.
Narrator: Some objects
need multiple layers
of silent material to
effectively kill any noise,
like with these gift bags.
So, quiet tissue.
Quiet bag.
Done.
Narrator: So, next time you see a scene
set in a grocery store, a bar,
or even just around the office,
look twice at the everyday objects
you can see, but can't hear.
We can all thank the prop makers for that.